[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar fast and reliable mobile
multiplex rt pcr the power of molecular
analysis made mobile
i am michelle ashton of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by ubiquitous
to learn more visit ubiquitonebio.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker lon
hua
application scientists at ubiquitou
lon you may now begin your presentation
okay so good morning good afternoon and
good evening my name is lon application
scientist here at ubiquitous
and just before i carry on i just wanted
to let each and every one of you know
that the team here at ubiquito term
greatly appreciate your attendance here
we just wanted to say thank you so much
for taking the time out of your day
to signing up and
to attend this webinar presentation i'm
personally very excited and looking
forward to showcasing to each and every
one of you the latest addition
to our qpcr device lineup
so
without further ado let's jump right in
so just to kick things off i thought it
would be a good idea to take each and
every one of you down memory lane to
tell you all about where we originally
started
and where we are now
and
what has happened along that particular
journey
so just to start we initially released
the freedom 4 which
is a 4 well
single channel configuration for a qpcr
device
which
progressed to the liberty 16
which
is a 16 well still single channel qpscr
device but now
upcoming which is the liberty 16 pro
we have retained that same
16 well configuration
but with
so much more added functionalities and
features
you definitely do not want to miss out
on what
is installed
so just to
go over some of the key highlights
that
the company ubiquitous has ascertained
along this particular journey
we have over 50
systems positioned in new zealand us
canada germany uk and asia pacific
alongside that with
we are one of the few winners especially
outside of the us
one of the few companies that have
received the
prestigious nih radix award
we have also received iso
1345 certification as well as an fda
emergency use authorization
for the liberty 16 with saliva direct
for
the purpose and detection of size cove 2
or covert 19.
so speaking of size curve 2 testing we
now look at some of the advantages and
disadvantages of
why
you would go about
implementing real-time qpcr or rtq-pcr
some of the advantages include
are
given what we've seen in the past two
years
with how
covert 19 has
essentially spread
right across the world it has remained a
gold standard for diagnosis of
infectious diseases
simply because of its reliability
sensitivity and also specificity
alongside that
it is also very cost effective in nature
so very much employable for a lot of
businesses especially in low resource
settings
and through the introduction of saliva
direct a saliva based testing
methodology it has allowed
so many more businesses to have access
to
accessible
and
easy to set up
and perform testing
as opposed to what was initially
proposed which was the nasopharyngeal
sample collection
process which
although worked
would not be most people's first choice
of
collecting a sample
in terms of the disadvantages of using
real-time qpcr there aren't that many as
you can see if you've ever worked in
a centralized lab or a hospital lab
you'll often see big bulky machines
that would perform real-time
qpcr um but they're often attached with
a hefty price tag
um some which will definitely be out of
reach for labs in low resource settings
they're relatively immobile
taking out relative valuable bench space
bench space that could be allocated for
other
important tasks as well
and especially during the pandemic when
central labs got overwhelmed these
machines caused a lot of backlog which
resulted in a lot of delays in output of
results meaning that people
were not allowed to return to work
because their results
could not get to them
as quick as they anticipated
so
business continuity was therefore
compromised for a lot of businesses out
there
so now looking at the power of molecular
analysis made mobile
you're probably thinking what does this
mean
how does that look
i'm about to tell you all about that
right now
so looking at the liberty 16 system
in the perspective of the detection of
covet 19 for a surveillance and
screening type of purpose
when we're talking about the sample
collection
it's easy and it's safe
and because we're using saliva it's
widely accepted
non-invasive
and allows for self-collection
making it easier for the operator
but also
easier for the person providing the
sample as they will be able to provide a
sample any time of the day
once a saliva sample has been provided
it is handed off to the operator the
operator then takes it through a very
simple one-step process which is heat
treatment so essentially heating the
saliva at either 95 degrees for 5
minutes or 65 degrees for 15 minutes
this process is extractionless and does
not require the use of protein ease k
so a very simple and fast sample
preparation step
once the saliva has been heat treated it
is then combined with a master mix a
master mix is essentially a combination
of reagents
combined together
the master mix is combined with the
processed or heated saliva sample it is
then
put into the liberty 16 process for
approximately 80 minutes
and once that 80 minutes has completed
you'll be able to view your results on
the proprietary liberty 16
app which is downloadable from the apple
app store
so just as a side
note the liberty 16 requires an iphone
or ipad so essentially an apple device
to operate
and
allow the device to be used
so just to reiterate the points
mentioned earlier ubiquitous the liberty
16 device is
iso 13485 certified
and we are also
one of the select winners of the
prestigious nih award
so now taking a look at some real world
testimonials so people
and businesses and labs that have
actually gotten the liberty 16 in their
hands and have actually tested it
with
real world samples so clinical samples
some of them to be named which are lts
renegade bio and adp biotech
we really thank them
for their support in trialing the
liberty 16 and providing us with such
valuable feedback
three of these are just
a small handful of
many other companies that have used the
libby 16 either for
an evaluation study
or have
used it
and have continued using it
as a way to perform low throughput
testing
or you can
transition it into a high throughput
machine as well
so just on real world testimonials we
then
went ahead and conducted an evaluation
study with
dr ann wiley located at
yale school of public health
whereby they managed to
discover and come up with a fast
protocol which actually achieved a
runtime of less than one hour
very fascinating very interesting and
quite profound for a device
this size
the reference is at the bottom of that
paper just in case you wanted to take a
look at that further
so it'll be at your convenience and at
your disposal
so speaking about
the paper
we
we understand the importance of early
detection and workplace setting
workplace testing
something that has definitely
been explored by many businesses around
the world
especially
over the past two years where
centralized labs have
essentially been bombarded with
an increased
number of test referrals for cover 19
with
bottlenecks
in getting plastic wares and supplies
and to keep up with the demand a lot of
businesses had has had to take matters
into their own hands and to
limit the spread to cut off the
transmission chain
and to essentially pick it up early so
that it wouldn't spread within the
organization
so now we're moving more into the case
studies side of things so
these case studies that will be
presented to you very shortly
are from companies and businesses that
we have worked with
personally on a personal basis
so essentially trying to figure out ways
and trying to
strategize with these companies on how
to
provide a safer working environment for
their business
and to help limit the spread and help
protect the people in the community
so first on the list is taylor
corporation so
as the image suggests they are in the
apple growing packing and exporting
business
they own roughly 300 hectares of land
spanning for miles and miles so they
export quite
a hefty load of apples and one of their
major concerns especially
when the omicron outbreak was first
cited was that they needed a solution
quickly
so what were some of the challenges
faced by taylor corporation well simply
there was delays and test results
returning from centralized laboratories
given that taylor corporation was
not in a major metropolis like auckland
here in new zealand
there wasn't a lot of staffing so test
results were delayed and there was also
the added fear that cover 19 would
spread within the
community the organization contaminating
their apples for export and potentially
resulting in them losing their export
license
which would allow them to trade
to other
countries so the next steps that they
took
to adopt the liberty 16 to implement
on-site surveillance testing
so that they had a way to identify the
health status of their employees staff
and apple pickers
which
led to an outcome of business continuity
retention
customer retention and also a safer
workplace
environment and community overall
second on the list we have port of
napier or napier port
their business is within the
international goods trading industry so
shipping
to and from the north island of new
zealand
similar to taylor corporation
they saw that omicron
was approaching and they needed a
solution
to allow their employees to have that
peace of mind
and for them to
feel confident and feel comfortable
coming into work
without potentially putting their own
families
at risk of potentially catching this
very serious and deadly virus
so the problem was to keep
essential supply chains going
and to control the virus spread and keep
employees safe the solution was
much like taylor corporation to
implement on-site testing through
ubiquitom's liberty 16 device
testing all employees daily so over 300
employees at the port of napier
help them
realize the value that delivery 16
could provide
so just to the top left hand corner we
have
just a very very simple table so
as of december
2021
for that particular calendar month there
were
2798 total tests performed of
negative test results coming back but if
we look down to march of
2022
total number of tests for that
particular calendar month was
2253 with 2 245 negatives and
eight non
negative results picked up
and
what what a non-negative result
essentially means is that
the liberty 16 device has
indicated that this person may
be highly suspicious highly likely that
they may have
caught
cover 19 or sascov2
next steps after that would be
is to encourage and to tell them that
they need to go and get a diagnostic a
clinical diagnostic test done for
the detection of cover 19 to
validate their current covet status
just because the liberty 16 was deployed
for surveillance testing only and it is
not
used as a diagnostic tool
the third on the list is balance so
balance agronutrients they're in the
business of fertilizer and chemical
manufacturing in terms of chemicals
we're looking at a chemical like ammonia
so they're in that particular business
in supply sales and advisory services
with over 700 plus employees
with a whopping 500 million dollars plus
revenue as of 2020
similar to
taylor corporation and napier port
they also saw the omicron wave coming
they needed a solution to combat
this particular
new strain of the virus so working
directly with the site manager sean
donovan we managed to put a plan in
place
to ensure that
workers employees and staff were coming
to a safe working environment
and providing that peace of mind to
everyone at work that
the organization was covet 19 free
so some challenges face was also delays
in sample processing at centralized
laboratory just because they were
absolutely
hammered and to the point where they
reach maximum capacity
a fear of cover 19 spreading within the
organization and potentially halting
manufacturing and distribution
so next steps was
adopting
the louis 16 for on-site surveillance
testing so they actually purchased two
liberty 16 devices because the one was
not giving them the throughput that they
needed so they ended up buying two
because the
investment in terms of capital
expenditure was not
high compared to if you were to buy one
of the bigger
um
bigger qpcr devices that you would often
see at a
centralized lab or hospital lab
so the outcome was that business
continuity and meeting demands
was achieved
but
more importantly a safer working
environment
and community was resulted as well
finally we have wipereras so one of our
local favorites here in auckland
new zealand so they're a
company a proactive collective to help
influence and advance multi economic and
social development with over 170 plus
employees
they needed
a solution
to also much like taylor corporation
balance and also
port of napier to be able to provide a
safer working environment
to be able to also help out the
community because they also had close
relations with the centralized labs here
in auckland they saw that they were
under a lot of pressure
and also
capacity wise they did not have the
capacity to
produce results in a timely fashion so
they wanted to help out
and so
what did they do so the challenges faced
was delays and test results returning
from centralized labs was recognized and
they did not want cover 19 to spread
within the organization affecting
communities and families um nationwide
and also within the community itself
that led to them acquiring
10 liberty 16 units setting up on-site
community surveillance testing but also
on-site surveillance testing for their
own
staff and employees
so optimization of testing was done by
the team at ubiquitous
this
resulted in an outcome of alleviating
stress face that centralized
laboratories
essentially taking the control back into
their own hands doing something on their
own
to take matters into their own hands and
for them to
have that peace of mind that we are
coming to a place that is safe and we're
also providing the people that we
are working with a way to know if
they've caught cover 19.
so with all of the case studies now
talked about and covered
what i want to bring your attention to
is actually this particular table
we is a very curated um cost analysis
table basically and essentially looking
at the three ways of detecting cover 19
today
so
on the far left
we have rt
pcr which is the one of the one of the
many strategies
but most likely the most common strategy
at detecting cover 19 today and as you
can see the total cost
it
would cost a lab to
get a result per sample
so basically per individual tested comes
to around about 30 us dollars
in the middle we have rapid antigen
testing so this can be done on site
at work or at home
that comes to
approximately an estimated price of 5.66
usd
but to the far right hand side that's
where
the big difference um comes into play
where
so for example if surveillance testing
was implemented
um and you were allowed to do on-site
surveillance testing
it would only cost
you know in the neighborhoods of 72
cents u.s
which is the cost per sample so
quite a significant difference when we
compare the costs from centralized lab
to a rapid antigen test as well so
definitely something to consider
and think about
whether or not you'd like to implement
on-site testing because the cost
differences are
very very significant and substantial as
well
so now that we've covered the
cost side of things
the case studies
the journey
and also how we got to where we are
today
it's finally time to showcase
the latest addition to our qpcr device
lineup which is the liberty 16 pro
the power of multiplex molecular
analysis made mobile
so just to kick things off with the
liberty 16 pro so you might be wondering
what has changed compared to the
currently available libby 16 compared to
this
um
latest iteration
well to start
when we're looking at
the
limit of detection or lod
the currently available
libya 16 device has an lod of around 12
copies per microliter
but with the liberty 16 pro we've
managed to push that right down to 1.5
to 3 copies per microliter
and just below the lod you'll have some
basic information as to
the throughput runs per day sample per
run and also the runtime
comparing delivery 16 which is currently
available in the liberty 16 pro which
will
be coming available very very soon
alongside enhanced sensitivity we have
now introduced multiplexing capabilities
something that has
been requested by
so many of our
partners and
customer sites
they definitely wanted to see this in
the new device
and we have definitely delivered this so
with the currently
available liberty 16 device it was a
single channel only device so
looking at the fluorescence dye fam but
now with the liberty 16 pro we're able
to look at
a wider range a wider spectrum
of fluorescent dyes these include fan
vic yakima yellow june texas red sci-fi
and also ato 647
so
it gives the end users
a
wider
range of essays that they would
be able to use
with the liberty 16 pro that they
couldn't use with the currently
available liberty 16 so allowing end
users to have a wider target detection
capabilities and also
with so many fluorescent dyes now
compatible with the liberty 16 pro
you'll have
improved productivity as well because
you'll have a lot more different assets
that you can use with this particular
low profile device
so now casting
your eyes and attention to
some of the
in-house
validation
type studies that we have done taking a
closer look at
what we've done
and how we managed to achieve the
lods that we have claimed
so
with each of these particular
curves
looking at the individual and specific
channels
three replicates was performed
for each of these
lod and house validation studies
so looking at the single plex assays and
four channels
the second is looking at the relative
fluorescence so
as you can see
consistency right across the board for
all of the
four channels green yellow red and deep
red
the third set of curves is looking at
the cdc flu a and b
sc2 multiplex assays so we performed
two replicates for this particular essay
looking at the lod compatibility
of this particular assay with the
liberty 16 pro
and
judging by
what i see and what i'm assuming that
you're seeing as well
very consistent in terms of
the
trajectory and also the
curves
finally
this is actually data that is hot off
the press so just received as of last
week by one of our fantastic senior
scientists
part of the team at ubiquitou the
modified
cdc monkeypox real-time qpcr duplex
essay ran on the liberty 16 so you have
the concentration in terms of the copies
per microliter on the left-hand side two
replicates was performed
the average cq was obtained
and this in the standard deviation
that follows on after that so
consistency is seen
across the board for the green channel
and also the deep red channel so very
exciting stuff in terms of the
developments the in-house validations
that was performed on the liberty 16 pro
so along with enhanced sensitivity and
also multiplexing capabilities
we've completely
redesigned
and have
implemented new and improved thermal
properties to the liberty 16 pro
which has allowed us to
ascertain
a faster ramp rate so the liberty 16 pro
will now have a ramp rate of 4.5 degrees
celsius per second which is almost a
two-fold increase compared to the
currently available
liberty 16 device
optimizing for all your pcr and qpcr
applications and needs
so finally alongside
increased ramp rates we have the design
the overall design of the liberty 16
pro
so
we overhauled the device we redesigned
the chassis
integrated a flip up and down transport
handle
along with an ipad and iphone support
stand
based on the image that you see up on
the screen there you see that the
notches
and grooves have been carefully
machined and integrated into the design
of the particular device which allows
for your ipad or iphone to sit
and rest
on the device allowing you to
save
even more valuable bench space
for if you want to set up another run
or if you wanted to reserve that space
to
do some
administrative work or sample
preparation
so
what i want to show each and every one
of you now is just a short video of what
it would be like having the liberty 16
pro in your hands
as if you were the person in this video
here today so let's let's have a watch
of this video just to give you a good
idea as to what it's like being
an owner of the liberty 16 pro
awesome so as you can see based on the
video itself it is a
fantastic machine which is incredibly
intuitive
it allows you to essentially
hit go place the iphone or ipad on the
device itself and essentially walk away
and come back when the
run has completed very very cool stuff
there if i do say so myself
so we're now nearing the end of the
webinar presentation
up on the screen you will see our lovely
product manager taylor verdun
showcasing the currently available
liberty 16 device and also the upcoming
liberty 16
pro
at the recent acc conference
on the left-hand side you'll be able to
see some of the specifications of the
liberty 16 pro for those that are
interested in
wanting to learn a little bit more about
this particular
new device
so essentially just to wrap things up
and to close
where
where will you see us next so we will
actually be attending the amp 2022
annual meeting and expo
located in phoenix arizona
during the days of november 1st to 5th
in terms of the liberty 16 pro you might
be wondering
well so how much is this particular
device so the pre-launch pricing
ends
on the 30th of september so you have
the whole of september to essentially
think about it make an informed decision
on whether or not this would be a good
fit
for your organization or business the
price is at us-5995
and i genuinely would like to emphasize
that you're essentially getting the
liberty 16 pro
for the same price that you would the
currently available liberty 16 but with
so much more added benefits and features
for the end user it's
in my mind an essential no-brainer so
if you are interested
and would like to
place an order
there is a non-refundable order fee of
u.s 250 dollars at the time of the
pre-order
once
this has been handed over to us you will
receive regular updates from us
telling you
at which step of the process
and build the device is at and when you
will expect to receive it
at the moment in terms of the
eta
we aimed and hoped to
ship devices out by the end of the year
but you'll receive regular updates from
us
some more information about
the amp 2022
we will be located at booth number
1610 where we will be presenting two
accepted abstract titles where you'll be
able to meet the team talk to us about
the liberty 16 pro
and all of that good stuff so definitely
if you're interested inquire with us at
ubiquito bio.com and one of
the many friendly members of the
ubiquitous team will definitely reach
out and respond to your inquiry as soon
as possible
and with all that said and done i just
wanted to
once again say thank you so much for
taking the time out of your day to sign
up and to attend this webinar
presentation
on behalf of the team at ubiquitone we
greatly appreciate your attendance and
we hope to meet some if not all of you
at the
amp 2022
expo
or online so thanks so much have a nice
day or
evening thank you vaughn for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
okay lon so our first question is um is
it android compatible and can i run it
off my
samsung or android device
that's a good question michelle so a lot
of our customers especially in asia
pacific has asked this um it is
currently not android compatible but it
is one of the many
items that are within our development
pipeline so something that will
definitely um be seen in the future
okay great thank you next question
uh how will i be able to export my data
so the data can be exported via the
liberty 16 app which is downloadable
from the apple app store
so all you need to do is just input an
email address of your choice and you'll
have all the data relating to the run
wait thank you
next question is there any regular
maintenance or calibration required for
the machine
yes so another common question that's
asked by
customers that we have worked with
as far as wherewith there isn't any
regular maintenance or upkeep that you
would need to do for the libby 16
although we do recommend um regular
you know calibrations and adjustments
but there isn't really a need for any of
that
okay great
well thank you so much lon do you have
any final comments for our audience
today
i
all i want to just say is thank you so
much for everyone and for their
attendance and and also their patience
for listening to this um
webinar presentation we hope to work
with some if not most of you
in the near future
okay great well thank you again
vaughn for your time today and your
wonderful presentation
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor ubiquitous for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their questions
as a reminder any questions we didn't
have time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care and goodbye
you